Adam Adam I'd like to say I did an
interview with Adam 22.
about six months ago now and I really
enjoyed my interview with him like
honestly I thought I thought he was very
polite and I'm not one if you're polite
to me and I've met you in real life I'm
really not gonna do stories on you when
you're in the news
I just you know I just think it's like
it's kind of
maybe in bad taste
you know because it's like I've met you
I don't know
however
guys if you know one thing about me I
will not do anything first
but if you call me misogynistic
I would like to talk about the real
misogyny So Adam 22 recently had a a
segment on with Destiny where he he said
had some comments saying that I say
misogynistic things that I'm
misogynistic tweets whatever
so today I want to talk about real
misogyny
I want to talk about are Modern Men Cox
okay
so let's let's talk about the average
wife so the average wife has slept with
over five people the average wife has
been on birth control the average wife
um one out of three chance she has an
STD one out of three chance she's had an
abortion so my question is
is the Modern Man a cuck
because while there is a degree of
separation I guess she's not sleeping
with anyone else now it used to be the
contract that a woman would only sleep
with you for life and now it's like well
she might have slept with someone a week
before she met you is that is that that
much better but now we have we have this
anomaly of men letting their wives
sleep with other people
roll the clip blessing so I've been with
my girl for seven years you just got
married we're not in an open
relationship but
from a porn perspective we shoot with
other girls stuff like that right yeah
but no other guys is busting her
coochian ass out well you guessed it
over the weekend oh no something like
that happened she filmed her first ever
scene with another man I know he was mad
[__] I'm angry I I agreed to it so I was
like I said Angry might not be the word
but she was kind of like disappointed a
little bit like you five like color I
cut that's your six you know I agree to
it she gave me a lot of outs on the way
in like she kind of kept telling me like
if you don't want me to I won't do it
I I said that I wanted her to do it I'm
like on top of millions of dollars Adam
you had to do that [__] fair enough but
I I told her I'm like I think you should
do it let's let's get it out how do you
five about it now she's 32 get you an
Old English no yeah no I don't need to
drown the pain no one goes but I was
kind of surprised because I feel like I
can like intellectualize it and from my
perspective
I don't think it should be a big deal
but then after she actually did it I'm
not gonna lie I did feel kinda odd the
way that I feel is the only time I get
like jealous of people is when I lose
access to somebody so for my wife if
she's [__] other dudes I don't care I
can [__] other girls that's fine because
we still have each other the only time
I'll get a little bit jealous is if I'm
like if there's a girl I'm seeing that's
like really cool and then she gets a
boyfriend and then we can't [__] anymore
do you guys see the level of cope like
they are both trying so hard
to like oh well I I don't get jealous
when they screw other people
I just
you know I just you know I miss having
access to them
do you guys believe this and even when
Adam's being honest right he's saying
oh you know like I kind of felt a type
of way about it and now my question to
you Adam is what is more misogynistic
for all of the the simp man and I'm
sorry because that is simping letting
your girl screw another guy when you are
a tall good looking multi-millionaire
okay and you accept her having sex with
another man for money
who is the real misogynist
who who hates women what's more
misogynistic telling them things that
are true
or pimping out women for money he uses
women's Beauty he monetizes women's
Beauty and I know a guy that age knows
that there are negative consequences for
women in the long run that do that type
of stuff much more than men if we live
in reality instead of peddling these
lies what is more honest to women
what is more honest you could call me a
misogynistic you could call me
misogynistic for saying that the Modern
Woman is a horror men shouldn't wife
[__] whatever
but
you're literally pimping young girls
at like 21 22 you're assisting them and
making a decision that will have
negative consequences for the rest of
their lives and my question is what is
more harmful to women and this is what I
mean it's like it's the hypocrisy the
hypocrisy of the left they'll say you're
the misogynist when what they are doing
is much more harmful to women than what
I could do
you are supposed to protect your wife
how is it protecting your wife
when you are letting her sleep with
another guy
it's officially been a week since I let
my wife do porn with another guy
I felt a little jealous at first but
overall it wasn't that big of a deal
she's watched me sleep with hundreds of
girls and it's never affected our
relationships sleeping with that
gentleman has been oh amazing for both
her career and our business plug talk
show overall I'm glad we did it and I'm
happy to report her vagina has returned
to its original
pre-bbc size do you see what
trouble we get into when we assume that
men and women are equal
this is what we get
Adam thinks because he has no
consequences for sleeping around
that she also will have no consequences
for sleeping around and what are the
odds she does this right after their
wedding it's just weird timing to me
um Adam I really hope you close this
marriage I really hope you
shut down I shut down the porn stuff
um you know honestly I'm gonna call Adam
Adam in the name of helping women
in the name of being you know I think we
should come together on an anti-misogyny
and sexism women are sexualized all
across the nation women are are in such
horrible positions from Men in positions
of power
from using and abusing us
um and just all of the blatant sexism so
you know I ask let's shut down the only
fans shut down the porn sites
and stop letting your wife sleep with
other men for money
to end misogyny let's come together
all right another one kind of weird
being called how being called a [__] is
supposed to offend me I saw the video of
my wife getting plowed
and I thought it was pretty hot if that
makes me a [__] so be it see what he's
trying to change reality he said he he
was jealous that's what he said now he's
saying it's hot
I wasn't oh I wasn't born with the
strength required to let another dude
bang my wife it takes hours upon hours
in the gym to gain this kind of strength
weak men will never understand this is
what happens when you go so far from
protection and provisioning like I just
for money was this worth it money
you're gonna live to be 80. 90 Maybe
and you have to live the rest of your
life
with knowing that you allowed another
man
whoever made this will be hearing from
my lawyer
okay this is funny
final thoughts is you know you can try
to change your biology you can't uh men
have a biological predisposition to be
territorial over the women that they
sleep with especially ones that have had
their children
sleeping around is different for men and
for women there are diff a million
studies that will tell you this
sleeping around porn is bad for women it
is not good for women and if you're
going to call me a misogynist I really
would like you to look in the mirror